one time I quit my job and as I was
about to quit my job my boss meeting him
I saw them eat her act like a dick I'm
like I'll quit text my friend yeah this
[__] is being a [__] I was all
half asleep and I look and about 15
minutes that I realized I text my boss
everything that I was saying to my
homies
oh yeah I had to quit after that one
that was the end what it was the end
[Music]
perfect what's up guys I'm Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys this is the Big
Jay oakerson episode thanks for being
here absolutely when we booked you I
already Leah told me to bring it up but
have you drove by I think it's another
comedy Laugh Factory I think it's by
Santa Monica oh no okay so it was really
sad I was trying I was telling her about
a couple weeks ago you bring that to him
and I told you about it dude they put
like R.I.P Bob sagging RP Gilbert
Godfrey and I was driving and I I told
you I even called my like bro I was
driving by I said big and I had a jam
with oh no and I looked online I was
like Marty and then I told him I thought
he was dead for about four minutes
it was the worst bro I I just I thought
I'd bring it up because that was the
first time I'm like
the first thing I said like can we break
them I love those moments of like
thinking like you saw the wrong thing
and then like but it's such a profound
emotional like jump when you have that
like oh yeah it's always in second long
spurts you know I mean I remember when I
toured with corn opening for corn and uh
when I got back like it was such an
experience and like at the end
of the tour
but I was saying goodbye to the Jonathan
Davis the lead singer I was like you
know what I was like hey I hope you know
to see you again and like hang sometime
whatever he was like take my number it's
like very coolly like I'm like yeah so
I'll just take your number
and he gives me his number and like when
I get
where I go after that I was on the road
somewhere I remember I wrote out a thing
to him like a thank you you know it was
long it was a little long and I I sent
it to my buddy Justin silver another
great comic I sent it to him to be like
hey can you like look over this thing do
I sound weird or am I just being like
fine and he was like it's a little long
but I think it's fine
I was like all right so then I sent it
to Jonathan Davis
and it was fine like there was nothing
like weird but later in the day just
like dude humor uh I took a picture or
of my dick and I sent it to Justin and
we just wrote I was like I was like hey
is this look right for my age or some
kind of dumb joke about it or whatever
but for the second I took it you know I
clicked on Justin's thing and and took
the picture and sent it like right in
the thread
and for I mean it's unmeasurable amount
of time how short it was but when I saw
the send thing going across and I what I
just saw was the words I wrote also to
Jonathan David because I sent it to him
the proofread so again it's a thing it's
a non-story but everyone gets it because
even though it didn't happen for that
moment I saw a female cross was like no
no no oh wait wait okay oh yeah I said
to him too but I was like could you
imagine like hey man thank you for
having me on the tour what an experience
it also goes and while we're at it
here's a dick big yeah and also yeah
this is look right for my age
everyone would go what if he sent one
back I go I would have just been there
we would have just been there then I
would have just act like it was on
purpose I go yeah I figured you were a
guy we could just like do dick pics or
whatever you see like the kind of guy
that we could just like bang out some
dick pics well I I uh one time I quit my
job and as I was about to quit my job my
boss meeting him I saw them weed I'm
like I'll quit text my friend yeah this
mother is being a [__] I was all half
asleep and I look in about 15 minutes
that I realized I text my boss
everything that I was saying to my
homies
oh yeah I had to quit after that one
that was the end what was the end my
daughter found out I smoked weed from a
wrong text thing which she was pretty
hilarious she's funny kid which is great
she's 20 now she was
almost 17 I think at the time she didn't
know you got high three years ago
um well what's funny about that is
she like the things I would you know you
hide it from when she's younger
obviously
and when she was younger my code word
almost like we'd go see movies every
Sunday with me her and her mom when I
was still with her mom every Sunday we'd
go see a movie and usually you're seeing
a kid-centric movie which sucks aren't
that great often and so I would go
downstairs in the basement and like
smoke weed before we left and I would
call it I go all right so it's my ex
I'll be like you you know finish getting
ready I'm gonna go do my thing and then
we'll take off and then one week when I
was going I don't know what it was I
just didn't go downstairs and my
daughter not knowing what it meant she
just goes aren't you gonna do your thing
and I was like all right I gotta start
watching what I'm saying something else
and then she she did say when she when
this texting happened that she knew but
only because she was like when her
friends started smoking pot and probably
her too uh that she was like oh that's
the smell in Dad's house yeah but the
way it became a conversation was
I was texting with her at one point my
friend Wayne
I was supposed to I'm going to his house
to hang out
front I was running late
for no particular read I was running
late and I texted him hey uh
you want anything from the deli I'm just
rolling a few joints up and heading over
I was like sorry I'm late I wrote a few
joints I'm heading over you want
anything from the deli and then I'd go
back to getting ready or whatever and
then I look at my phones for my daughter
she goes grab me a sandwich dog and I
wrote back I wrote back what
which is such a dumb it's not a
conversation in a conversation like you
could do that you know I mean like huh
yes he's there so I went what and then
30 seconds later I was like I gotta call
her and tell her that's the most it's
more insulting to be like but for a
minute in my mind was going I'm like do
I text back and be like I didn't I don't
know why that that wasn't uh I'm like
she knows technology better I mean she'd
be versing to go it's impossible when
you're saying yeah so I was just like
yeah
so for everyone out there that has not
bought your father's day gift yet pay
attention to what we're about to say I
have no fear manscapes got you this
Father's Day the leaders and below the
belt waste grooming capabilities and
Technology guys manscape's back again
this year with the complete package for
your dad's package so check out
manscape.com Yola use code Yola to check
out it's 20 off and free shipping let's
start off with the performance package
4.0 inside this package you're gonna
find the lawnmower at 4.0 then after
that you're gonna find the weed whacker
2.0 ear nose hair trimmer and you
already know the crop preserver ball
deodorant performance boxer briefs and
the travel bag can't forget about the
beard hedger Pro kit for all the dads
around the world included is the beard
hedger trimmer the beard shampoo and
conditioner beard oil beard bomb and two
free gifts their signature beard comb
and scissors so it's Father's Day get
your dad a gift right now go to
manscape.com use our code at checkout
that's y-o-l-a the code is Yola get 20
off plus free shipping remember
manscape.com code Yola is 20 off plus
free shipping have a happy Father's Day
I think it's real funny that the rose
I'm in trouble oh no I don't for me I
had kids young so I went from hiding it
from my parents to hiding it from his
kids like immediately pretty much to my
daughter was I was 23 when she was born
so she oh she's 21 right yeah
this man's daughter was here last
episode two hours ago gave him a giant
joint and halfway
light you don't like it and then I'm
like
oh yeah she's never seen you actually
inhale she watches the show but doing it
in person I've been tipped way down
14. she's 14. I would say it's way
different it's interesting they're gonna
be fine you know I mean like there's
there's a thing like now it's still
funny like I know she smokes I don't
think she smokes a lot but she smokes
for sure but yeah but she um
we're at a point now like if she comes
over my house or we go to a concert or
something like that and like
with other people I'm like okay I'm
gonna smoke a joint real quick before we
go in and just make her stare at us
because I'm like I can't be the guy
who's supposed to be with you yet I
didn't I didn't find the families who
did that to be all that like enviable
when I was younger even though I don't
think they were there was so much more
than that things but all these were the
house they were like these are the
parents who were like as long as you're
here you know I'd rather smoke and you
go
I guess there's a neces there's a
necessity for that place in the world
for kids but also I'm like those
families were always like [__] up
every single day as they got older it's
like they're all just kind of like
failures and whatever and you're like
yeah no one's ever like a doctor what
was your child well I had the cool pot
house
no I uh my homie Ryan
Ethan's man you could drink that his mom
should buy us beer I was gonna say
outside shot too those the mothers of
those families were some one of the kids
yeah I hope not I was there for years
dude when Louis J Gomez tells that story
about like his friend's house I forget
like his mother was like a toothless
like 55 something year old lady or
something she like crawled in bed with
him like going to sleep over started
breathing in his ear and then just left
again that was like a house where it was
like yeah do whatever you want mm-hmm no
not for me but on that before we get on
the next yeah we got some weed over here
I rolled joints for earlier and now
we're ready to smoke oh yeah first two
guests don't smoke weed really I really
thought they were good dope as usual I
really thought they were gonna
but I told my daughter like you got to
give yourself a chance to just be a kid
like I didn't start smoking weed so I
was like 19 20. I started my 20s to my
early 20s I tried I went to Amsterdam oh
was the first time that I like really I
tried it before that and I had that
first situation of like uh
you know there's always that first
something they say sometimes you don't
feel it necessarily or you just get
tired that's kind of what it didn't
really hit me like that
but then I uh was it good weed though in
comparison to like no it was just trash
no I mean I started smoking weed in the
you know yeah they're very easily
they're still pulling seeds and all that
kind of stuff but it was right at the
end of that 1922 so I didn't have like
uh like a long time of like [__] like
all weed's pretty good at this point now
yeah I think you have to go out of your
way to find like real weed but what
about because you live in New York right
so even in New York you're talking about
it's hard to find weed uh yeah I think
yeah everyone's got pretty good stuff
now the dispensaries are there so oh
that's right New York which is pretty
Corner dude every corner has a van they
sell [__]
yeah New York's pretty wild they're
doing it's expensive in the dispensaries
because I guess they told me there's
technically a thing they're not
dispensaries
because they're not affiliated with like
a grower which I think is like one of
the qualifying things yeah they're
basically like retail
so it's like you're getting mark up on
like that so
you know my favorites right now the baby
Jeter and you're gonna say I love them
yeah the small joints like Point threes
right yeah yeah they're great do you
ever see them but I mean they're like
sixty dollars
yeah that's too much
you ever see them do the makeshift
Church it'll be like in a business park
and then it's like church of you know
community and you like this they do this
in Orange County you go into this office
suite and then you go past security and
they got a steeple and that's the
waiting room and [__] and it's
technically a church that sounds kind of
tight
it is oh that's kind of hard they should
name all the strains Blasphemous [__]
when I've done a
like weed shows before I'm the first
place that would do that I'd go to
Toronto it's called the other round
Comedy Club it was great she knew what
she was doing and she owned a head shop
next door
she just patted the right hands of like
the local police to like let her do
these like indoor weed smoking shows
it was still illegal there it wasn't
like when it was all legal like it is
now so she in the front she would sell
like
Sierra Mists and like you know little
Cheeto bags and all these little snacks
and stuff they make and the back was
this cool showroom where they just had
like lighters and uh rolling stuff and
everything you bring your own weed and
people just and it was so fun to do but
you had to get used to 100 of the shows
I've done there they have a staff of
like pretty girls who look like gypsies
basically those were like you know
they're hippie girls yeah and then you
know when you're on stage at some point
of the show there's going to be a guy
laying on the ground they call it
Greening out it's like laying on the
ground while a gypsy girl like while his
head's in her lap and she like rubs his
head like you gotta get over that being
weird like oh we lost another guy all
right get one of those Gypsy [__] in
here yeah those things are faking that
[__] yeah yeah
where's one of those hot gypsies to rub
my forehead
I was in this one
this one all right we were way off topic
Legion of skanks your podcast yeah all
right how long has that been going on
I think we're like 11 almost 12 years
man wow yeah it's been going for a bit
and it was a cool like to watch it like
that's like one of the besides like
stand up like the career stand up
but that's like
helped along the way it's like you get
to levels and then you find you know you
know you need a manager at this point or
a lawyer an agent those people kind of
handle
the stuff the podcast was so like our
first year I think when we were done we
were like like 400 people are listening
to an episode and it wasn't like a we're
blowing it we're like 400 [__] people
are listening like it's crazy
there's no way to advertise it so it's
people who were like I'll listen to your
thing you know what I mean I'm like
that's awesome to be where it's at now
is like unreal it's insane unfucking
believable honestly and I would imagine
like 12 years your audience helps you
guys probably get through the pandemic
more so than other comedians oh man if I
didn't have like Broadcasting
like during the pandemic I'd have been
[__] and you know you said you have
kids too so it's like I would have been
like in such a that was great also to
like just get through it like mentally
just have something to go do all the
time not talk about
I was gonna love that [__] I was like
you don't want me to do [__] and go
nowhere and just film at my house and
not be bugged
oh yeah and then you realize faster too
like there is something so much to like
like Zoom episodes of stuff
are fine they're fine and like you could
do we've caught a rhythm like we do our
second one on Legion of skanks is on
Zoom
every week because this way we can still
we're not together you know it's hard
for us to get together but we could get
down in front of our computers for like
two more hours a week
and it's like and we've kind of figured
out how to do it but I mean there is no
replacing like the energy of being in
the same room like it's different it's
way way different we've turned out a lot
of guests we've we would just be so
stoked for because like no we don't we
can't do Zoom bro because the first time
in meeting somebody I feel like and plus
it's Marty now we're just high-ass fools
and most people like who are you like
after a while it's fine you guys are
cool against each other when it was a
celebrity on the zoom one to be the
worst you've never met and you're like
dude this is so cool so we have Method
Man here he's looking a box and I'm like
this guy's not going to get my funny
like this no it's different especially
because you know it's like Zoom too and
there's when there's like six people on
yeah the last you know you're like uh
Method Man blah blah blah you know weed
smoke in her [__] whatever the dumb
thing he says and he's like
he didn't like it
you guys do it live every episode
basically aside from like um I mean I
know it's alternating but like we just
ganks the the in front of the audience
show is live every week the other one's
pre-record
um bonfire the SiriusXM show with me and
Robert Kelly now is uh is live you have
a podcast with R Kelly is the first
thing I thought so we got a podcast R
Kelly bonfire Robert Kelly is a
brilliant comic he just and he's uh you
know Robert Bobby is no because he was
bringing him up like it's not R Kelly I
know that but what was so funny was when
that first season of that documentary
series came out how much they said like
they called him Robert Kelly like I had
him come on there is before he was my
co-host like he came out as a guest with
me and Dan Soder and uh I held him to
the Flames over I was like he's you know
did Japan was obviously he's like dude
it's not me I go well explain this and
it was like and that's when Robert Kelly
stole my 12 year old daughter and
started having sex with her I go sounds
like you're talking about you Robert
Kelly
it was also good because at one point in
life he and he doesn't care now because
it's like he's past that point but there
was a you see the change in people's
names as they get older like I remember
Bill Burr was Billy Burr for the longest
time and then Bobby started to get like
a hung up thing at one point about like
uh it's Robert Kelly not Bobby Kelly and
uh she's like okay so it's been sticking
to that you go okay Robert Kelly gotcha
why do you [__] pee on children
yeah I still say Chappelle Show might
have crushed that was the hardest thing
I've only cried a few times
[Music]
bro come on I had that on CD when you
used to Burns I mean my uncle John off
Kazar oh I don't know his limewatch you
guys use LimeWire because I didn't know
how to do it and then I would buy the
blanks from Walmart remember this packs
yeah everybody should [__] burn their
computer from
if your computer was in the LimeWire
days because
that's when you would download like porn
on it based off of
non-nonsense description of stuff and it
usually was pretty good but you get
stuff and you're like is this like a
legal porno you know you don't know so
you watch it you're like oh yeah sure
you did and that's one of those things
where you're like you delete it and
you're like is it deleted like throw
this thing in the ocean put it on a boat
bro I don't it's always a joke if you
were dying fast and the effect they're
like
you know it's like all right you're
you're alive right now but as soon as we
move this car like you're gonna die I'm
like get my daughter destroy Daddy's
computer
burn my phone with me in the crematorium
I want to be buried with my phone dude I
gotta be honest if I was gonna be buried
with something six football
so when they found me into any like yo
this fool was bawling his ass off
no not a sandwich like a viking or they
could plug in your phone and see all the
oh you took and whatever else exactly
said to Jonathan Davis how did that come
about the corn thing yeah it's so funny
because uh
I just prefer my specials coming out and
we I I don't even know what my YouTube
page was like beforehand it's not really
how I did anything so um
they had to get you know for the special
they wanted to be as simple as possible
like I guess YouTube Big Jay oakerson
and they had it as big jokers in comedy
because they were like big Jefferson's
taken and we found out that was from
uh a manager that got that for me years
ago
and uh his name was Reverend Dave
ciancio he was he managed Museum he
managed musicians so he was you ever
heard of the band Shadows Fall they're
like a metal band from like a couple
years back and he was like their manager
and he was he worked like music
promotions but I did a TV show on IFC
that was about a band and so there's a
lot of music people involved in the show
and and that booking agent I had no
agent or no manager they were like we'd
like to talk to you and then like I kind
of met with them and they're like well
we can't really send you out on the road
like for anything like we're music
Bookers and wouldn't even make sense but
we'd love you to meet this guy who wants
to get in the comedy management
and this and Dave ciencio
and I said they just got the thing back
from so someone reached out to him and I
I wish him all the best he's great
but he knew nothing about comedy really
and like he didn't even know enough to
for me to not know that he knew nothing
about it but through his and honestly
our managership just ended it was even
like a I had to fire him it was just
like one day we just didn't hit each
other up anymore about it you know what
I mean about management just and I was
like I guess I'm like free to sign with
somebody else but he uh
in one day two thing of all that's why I
said like as far as like life-changing
things that I've done or things that
like
not Define me but like defining moments
of my career is I think going on those
tours was one of them
and I did three I did two Mayhem fests
and one corn by themselves [__] and he
called me one day and he was like all
his calls were always like hey you want
to do a VFW show where you're going to
be opening for get this you know someone
you've been doing it longer than or
something you know or just like someone
who I'm like this guy shouldn't be
headline
like you know what I mean it was like he
just didn't know and uh but then when
they called I mean it was like back to
back phone like like an hour between
phone calls he was like you want to go
uh on Mayhem Fest it was the first one
he offered he was like six you know 30
cities or whatever and like you'll be
basically emceeing it and doing like a
little comedy bit you know oh sick and I
[__] with the crowd so it was like yeah
I'm like let's do it I go that'd be
amazing and then he called a few hours
later he goes how about before that do
you want to go out for like six oh six
by four weeks four or five weeks before
that uh do you want to go out with corn
on like a smaller venue tour which was
awesome but to warm up also not even
just to like be like that intimate of a
situation with corn which rules
but like uh doing the they did a tour
that I just happened to jump on this one
called The Ballroom Blitz tour where
they were playing some places like a
thousand seats only
so like I can control that with Co you
know it's not like when I did Mayhem
Fest it's like Arena by the end of the
night it's not a reason it's like an
Amphitheater and not that these are
terrible places for comedy I've done
comedy them a bunch on Oddball tour or
comedy tours and what's different about
this is they're like waiting for Rob
Zombie to go on and they're like who's
this fat [__] Roadie who just grabbed
the microphone and started assaulting us
they didn't know who I was and I'm like
hey look at this girl up here with the
whatever you know and they're like [__]
who is this [__] and I had to get
them doing the smaller one was because
they also didn't know me there too and
it was like but I had to learn how to
like kind of control that
that energy of like a rock show and so I
was able to do it more when I went on
tour but yeah we accomplished nothing
together
in the comedy where I think he's still a
burger blogger he might manage music
still great guy
um but yeah I'll never like [__] not
thank him over and over again because
it's almost like
it kind of like made the it's funny and
almost like created like a myth
of me more because I tell that so much
because it's such a big thing but the
myth is like it also reads like wrong
because I'm not like they're like oh Big
J's like the metal guy like you want to
go do Coke and whatever and blah blah
and hit a strip club all night I'm like
oh
no not really like I'm gonna go back and
watch like 2020 in my room or whatever
you know what I mean like it's not what
they're hoping for at all you want to do
a rail off that guy's dick
they really think it's like you're in a
world like of that kind of thing oh you
at least play guitar right looking like
that like no
no whose idea was it to pair the comedy
with corn I don't know I have no I don't
know I don't know if that was a pitch by
my managers maybe because he was yeah
because because he loves you because you
guys one of my favorite stories is
and this is hilarious talk about having
like no integrity
when you're young in stand up because
you just want to work you know I mean
and you want crowds and when I came off
those tours
uh
uh they told me they give me another
call and they go hey would you have any
interest in like would you want to do it
again in a few months on the music as a
weapon tour that's corn
and Disturbed were the main acts and I
was like
yeah I'm like this is crazy I'm like yes
I will do that again
and they go okay and then they came back
to me with an offer they go all right so
you know uh corn is in like they love
you so like you can go uh Disturbed is a
little more like resistant so
for spending the money so it goes it
just it would be you're gonna make what
you made last time the same like it's
not a raise or anything and I was like
yeah that's I didn't care at all and
then they go all right great then they
come back and they go uh okay actually
it's gonna be less than you made last
time
and I was like
okay you know I'm like okay I think it's
still like because I also I've done it
twice now these two tours that I was
like oh I have like the
like I got it how to do it now like
there won't be shows like yeah so like I
can go back and do it now and probably
even do better promotion for myself by
like I know now from the very first show
when I go out there they're gonna be
like what or they know me from last
concert and be like oh it's the guy
so I was like yeah I'll do it for the
last month it was like less it's always
like money and tour expenses they say
which is like sleeping on the bus and
food or whatever
so less money and tour expenses I go
um
it's going to be tough you know I have a
daughter and stuff she was like eight I
guess the time or so and I was like uh
I was like yeah it is worth it though
for that promo yo yeah I'll do it I'll
I'll do it for a little less money
uh then they come back and they go
um all right so this sucks he's like but
they're coming back they're saying
no money
but tour expect like so you can not
spend money to go on this but like uh
we're not going to give you any money
and I go oh I I gotta figure this I
gotta talk about my wife my ex-wife now
but I was like we gotta talk about it
and we
we sat down and I pitched her such a
poetic speech of like that she was on
board I I couldn't even guess what our
plan was financially on this
because I called back to be like I was
like when I was talking to her I'm like
dude the promotion though I was like and
now I got it so it's like this could be
maybe it's life-changing or so who knows
to this point she was like
we'll figure it out like we'll make it
work like yeah if you want to do it do
it
um it'll be like five weeks or so so I
go
I call back and I go it feels like a
real tail tuck you know but uh tell them
okay I'll do it and they came back and
they go Disturbed doesn't want a band or
a comedian on tour they don't get it
they don't get the idea and I was like
what and they go I feel like they were
trying to get you to have some
masculinity and dignity and go like uh
like they were trying to give me a
chance to be like I'm good insulting
[__] you guys and like you know like on
my terms and they just get lower and I
just kept going like who does that put
it a little further in my ass I'll let
you know if it hurts
so no it's just yeah it always came back
he goes I'm good with that I'm the
Disturbed I need you know if I
interviewed Dave Draven years later
lovely guy by the way and like uh
he was kind of he was sweet to tell my
story he's like
he's like really he's like I'm sorry man
because I made him laugh the whole show
and he was like he's like he was like
he's like oh it's really cool he goes
yeah I don't know like maybe I just
didn't get her something but he was like
and they sent me an invite to like uh I
wasn't able to do it but it was pretty
cool they did their homecoming show the
House of Blues
and you know it's
about 11 years later after I've done
that that gig so you know he's a
different guy I'm sure too he was like
oh come do this kid I could but I'm like
oh that's a pretty cool offer though
that'd be awesome oh like from Chicago
she went out there just bombed like this
is what you would have got yeah
12 years later I'm not any better at
this this is what you would have got
they Disturbed fans are you you paid me
for this one by the way if it makes
sense maybe and this is the first moment
exclusive that I've ever had this
thought
Disturbed music it's the part but
Disturbed music is I like that because
you have to go out there and be like you
know Mommy didn't love me and you have
to hit me why don't you die and I'm
sitting in a hole in my room and a
little boy in my head like I'm here so
to have a guy go out there and be like
is this fat girl your girlfriend
or like whatever the dumb [__] I'm you
know like when someone's being shitty in
the audience yeah like just go out there
and they're like that's not really the
end and I'm like he's right different
Vibes like corn definitely on their own
thing like had
it's not so much of a Cutters Vibe it's
more of letters it's more of like uh
girls like you know like like bright
green yeah like stuff yeah exactly
that's a great green striped sock on one
side yeah yeah right on the other
exactly it's like it's much more of that
than you know having like uh 40 braids
coming off your hair or something
than that you know I mean like uh then
Disturbed Disturbed definitely like the
you know 17 year old wearing like a
priest outfit or something Disturbed
they were wild he looked at the guy from
Anthrax to me I always mixed up yeah
this looked the same to me as a kid I
don't know but damn Disturbed I haven't
heard that's fools in forever we just
saw corn what last year with with the
system down amazing
I wanted to go to that uh oh it was good
thing in Vegas we went to the one here
yeah no I know they did but they're
doing uh one day in Vegas it's like
Vegas is doing this thing now with these
tours they're like
a genre and everybody ever in it really
like the the posters like you know big a
lot of names ten thousand acts and I
mean like in the this writing is bands
like body count and stuff where you're
like damn that's like a pretty big band
and they're small and they're written
like down here yeah it's like
it's pretty nuts and System of a Down
corn tool I think
who's the best that's a great
remember those New Year's goals you
promised yourself you stick to
hellofresh is here to help you eat
better by delivering directly to your
door fresh ingredients and easy recipes
taking the hassle out of dinner time
spend more time doing the things you
love instead of going to the grocery
store like Marty said let Hill fresh
take the hassle at dinner time they're
going to deliver fresh recipes fresh
ingredients to your door ready to go
guys how much is your time worth are you
a nutritionist you got time to be
driving to the store through traffic
wandering around the aisles putting
together recipes doing all this research
no you don't your time's worth more than
that hellofresh is saving you time
saving you money making you healthier
you know what it's like to look in your
fridge and go there's like nine things
in there I can make but I don't know
recipes I can Google it hellofresh helps
you eliminate all that every week
they're giving you 40 new recipes so
you're fit you can't even eat 40 times
in a week but if you can hello fresh is
there to help you out go to
hellofresh.com
yola65 and save 65 off hello fresh with
free shipping that's hellofresh.com
forward slash yola65 and don't forget to
use code Yola 65 that's going to get you
65 off your whole order plus free
shipping remember it doesn't get any
better than that for America's number
one meal kit
Rock shows are wild as hell his wife
loves Rock Marty you went to the rock
show that was your first show right yeah
yeah I've been to like a lot of metal
shows and like backyard shows a
punctures my mom and my sister are all
into that you remind me of the guy from
uh
did you ever see Shane Gillis showed me
this video so much for of what uh of the
guys it's it's La for sure it's uh
like a local like young teenage like
Mexican metal band
I guess and it's their it's at a Denny's
and he goes uh and he starts and he goes
well you see this for he goes what's up
what's up
Dennis and then it cuts out it's like
they're moshing and Denny yeah Denny's I
find that video like sweet in a weird
way because I'm like
you'll get to a point if you're a
performer in your career where you're
just gonna be like you know how long do
I got to do this and I'm still sitting
at the old like you know the funky
chuckle Shack and wherever you know what
I mean yeah but there's a time when you
would tell everybody you know it's like
yo come see me at the [__] funky
chuckle Shack oh for sure you know as
I'm saying if you were playing in the
back of a Subway as you go yo back room
of Subway like we're doing a show you
weren't embarrassed to tell girls you
like that that's I love that they're in
that phase
what the [__] is up Denny's yeah I
remember that the backyard shows are two
bucks
California is probably much much uh
better for that I feel like your
hometown bands like you know my girl's
from Hermosa so it's like Pennywise and
uh Sublime and all that yeah let's bury
a king on the beach [__] that was my uh
my mom my mom I grew I grew up on
classic rock so I didn't get into rap
till I was I told you 15ish but then
like so it was a very different it was
very different but the metal shows and
all that [__]
um I don't like getting punched at no I
don't appreciate the mosh bits I step
back in full still but and I'm not I'm
small I watch it I love watching it oh I
love seeing let's do the back the
breakfast the coolest thing of uh of
being on tours and I was like you can go
like side of the stage and like you see
what they're seeing and it's like whoa
intense doing that with like Slipknot
and [__] like you just stand on the side
stage like you know that's great that my
me and my ex-wife's early one of our
early dates
I was trying to impress against like I
said the innocence of like uh what you
brag about at the time like I was so
confident that I got her I was like I
know some people over at the local radio
station like uh I got us free I got I
got us hooked up for Oz Fest
I know but it's like it's hooked up in
the most like you're on the lawn like
this isn't a seat it's like a good seat
it's like I can get you in the doors
I've got all the backstage pass or
anything like I'm in there but I'm like
I got us in you know the thing we're in
the worst place you can see if I never
sat anywhere besides that my whole life
I was always nosebleeds and whatever
so uh we went and I was I still I still
am of his music I guess big Marilyn
Manson fan oh yeah and he was uh closing
before Sabbath or Ozzie that year and
Slipknot was before Marilyn Manson and I
just knew what something I looked like
in their thing and the one Wait and
Bleed I think song
it's so but they do a thing that I was
great when I went on tour with them it
was my most favorite thing to watch out
because they do it every show when they
do the song spit it out
they do a long long thing of like making
all the people in the crowd get down
like squat down
and then he starts like the ramp up
thing at the end of that song and then
he goes um some jump the [__] up in the
hole
whatever Arena Amphitheater is like
every you see that kind of explosion of
people
they still do it to this day when I
was uh
when I was brought her to the lawn
Slipknot came on it's so funny what a
fan I am of them now but like again I I
watched Wu-Tang once and walked out
before Rage Against the Machine when
I've made a lot of dumb decisions when I
was a kid just like a teenage kid like
not really knowing the more
and I've always liked all music it's not
that I was like that's Rock and I'm a
rap guy and I'm like I was in all this
something it was on that first album and
I even do like this song now but I just
that song Freedom by them didn't catch
me
it just didn't catch me so I was just
like and we just saw Wu-Tang perform
shittily you want to just get out of
here
and we laughed and I'm like I just
watched them twice at Madison Square
Garden on this last tour their last run
there it was I wish I would have seen
them young that was so great
um so still then forgot the train of
thought oh so uh
I didn't know that's me so I was like
hey you want to go like walk around the
festival area like you know get
something to eat while slip nuts on and
we'll come back from Marilyn Manson
as we walk around and I hear Slipknot
kind of saying good night
and so I'm like oh let's go get some a
good area on the lawn since you have to
be like you know at the right angle and
the right close to even see it you're
gonna be watching screens anyway
let's go get a good area so we get like
trapped in the lawn of people like we're
in it there's a lot of people but we can
see this is heavy slope and they uh
Slipknot comes back out you want a
little bit more The Encore they were the
the second co-head liner it's like that
seemed like a weird thing they're coming
out and they play they rule they come
out and they play uh one of the songs I
forget and then the second one is that
spit it out song and I don't they've got
a lot of fans there and they uh
when they're they'd get to the park
everybody get on the ground
me and my Hispanic girlfriend who grew
up thinking her mother telling her that
like
rock music is evil
she's standing there with me and
everyone's getting down around us
a lot of bros a lot of khaki shorts and
and they know something
and me her and like
I mean
15 other people in the entire lawn are
not down it's everyone's really abiding
by this and we're like what is this I
don't even know what it is but everyone
seems to know and they're looking at
each other with like like
like you were ready to [__] [__] up and
I was like I'm almost looking I'm like
there's no way to because everyone's
down you can't even like finagle your
way like let's get to the let's get to
the stairs and like let's wait for this
to end
we're just in it dude how many years
I mean I've never
in hindsight it was probably like
exhilaratingly fun but in the moment it
was terrifying like it was just but it
was I was going up and down but my feet
weren't hitting the ground you're just
like attached to people and everyone
moving and I was like that's [__]
scary so I like to observe him I love
the energy it creates you know what's up
what the [__] is up Denny's but like I'm
never like one I've never wanted to get
into I've never been listening I watch
music
with such like
I mean girlishly dick ride or energy I
mean I'm really like dude that looks so
far comedy comedy is like the strip down
of that except for like Def Jam and a
couple of like certain Comics but it's
not a braggadocious like yeah you go
swing your [__] thing it's most to be
like hey I've looked stupid here have
you ever felt stupid have you ever done
this dumb thing I've done it's a lot of
that
and but like music you get to go up
there and you know even you're a guy who
goes home later and you know takes a
nasty [__] and breath stinks like at one
point he's on stage he's in a position
where you're like this guy's a god dude
like he's controlling these people with
like very calculated microphone holds
and the way he looks at the crowd I
think that's awesome I'm so intrigued by
that that's why I love Marilyn Manson so
much I'm like yo this guy's doing
Broadway up there
it's crazy
um there's a fat guy in a vest yeah
that he's good he's gonna cut yo I
brought he's my favorite ever is he
really performers wise and I love his
music too but like I think the last few
years have been whatever but his
original like first five or six albums
here are pretty amazing
and the way he changed like through them
but man I took my
by the time me and my girlfriend like
were dating it's been a long time now
but like he was already past this Prime
and the two times I took her to see him
like the first time he did like okay
and she tried to be like because she
knows how much I like love him she was
like it was really good and I was like
and she likes the music too but I was
like it wasn't it wasn't I feel bags
I've showed you on videos and whatever
like what this guy used to be and that
wasn't it then we went to like a year
later so the Chicago Open Air Festival
was called it was like a three-day tour
something but the night I was able to go
like Marilyn Manson was one of the
headliners
and so we go and watch them there so
this is a soccer field of some sort in
Chicago and it's
huge and the stage has enormous screens
next to it
and he comes out and starts playing uh
you know his set and it's like you
already tell us just like the energy of
when he was younger you know he's an
older guy now I guess but he came out
and they're just felt the big screens
filming is just straight up his fat
rolly neck and it just looks bad and
you're like damn even when he was like
ugly when he was younger there was
something like artistically like
beautiful about it I was like he's so
cool in this goofy outfit but he's like
doing such a cool thing now it just
looks like you know oh your uncle's
trying to put on his old clothes but so
uh
Antichrist Superstar is one is a great
song of his and and
when I first saw him ever when I kind of
discovered him live that was in the
first I didn't know any of these guys
music and I just saw him in concert
except for sweet dreams her friend was
gonna have an extra ticket
and um
he [__] like
they like he would do the grossest [__]
and it would be cool when we're at this
open-air thing he uh anti-christ
Superstar when it came on when I was
younger it's like the lights go out
there's this weird eerie music playing
the music hits and
it comes it's supposed to be like satire
of like the uh the Third Reich like
Hitler you know I mean it's like these
it's you know he's up there as like a
preacher on this big uh oh my Podium and
then there's like uh
MTV or something yeah absolutely I
remember it was like he does uh and it's
supposed to be provocative and whatever
the thing it's uh that was that was so
cool I even kind of like um
my Comedy Central special I did in 2016
or 17. the intro of it is inspired by
that very much like when I showed the
band that I had what I wanted I was like
I love this like you know obviously
don't make it look nazi-ish yeah
obviously don't do the hatred but I was
like but I like the idea of like the the
kind of flags kind of hanging behind you
of like whatever the artwork is that was
just pushing the limit yeah that was all
he was doing so I go I love that now
he's doing that he's not the headliner
so it's still sort of light out which
kills
on my radio show on Series XM we did a
whole episode about that daytime evil
doesn't work when you have like Swedish
metal bands playing at like four in the
afternoon I saw cradle fill while Birds
I really like metal music well why was
the Oz Fest I wouldn't have gone to see
them on my own but cradle filth like
it's like Swedish or you know Norwegian
death metal and like it was just birds
tweeting and everyone like hot like
sweating on their head yeah it's like
it's just such nice different vibe the
thing for that so Marilyn Manson's doing
Antichrist Superstar at this Chicago
Festival
the things drop down but there's no
mystery to it because it's like daytime
still so there's not like Darkness
that's hiding at all he's on the podium
and lastly before I've seen this guy do
so much gross [__] before and it was
cool nasty [__] that I would be like
puke if I saw but I mean like you know
exactly blowing snot Rockets he's pissed
himself on stage before that I watched
anybody draws like attention to it where
he's like I don't give a [__] kind of
thing and you're like yeah dude
this guy he's on that thing he's got the
neck going and they're shooting him and
when that that song that militant like
song is playing and he's trying to do
the the televangelist you know thing
he's doing and he goes he goes and blows
a snot rocket
it's just
it just catches his lip like this and
the crowd I mean it's a soccer stadium
and everybody goes oh he has no idea how
close that is on the big screen
there you go oh
and then it like the cameras pull away
from that like go to something else to
to just go for something else and then
like you know for like five six seconds
and then it goes back to and when it
comes back to him he's doing this thing
oh he shouldn't blow it off his lips and
I just remember looking at my girlfriend
just like going like this is not him
I'm sorry
that open Air Festival was also one of
the
hardest I think I might just
filibustering are you guys supposed to
ask questions no this is why we're here
family this is why we're here Grant City
we call it it's a snot Rockets
this is our comfort zone I am
in that same Festival
I made another ass of myself because of
uh a dumb thing but I
when I this is well before I went on
tour with corn in like 2000 something
early my friend Craig Gass who's a
comedian who was very in with like uh
musician like bands he had some like
kind of tie into like you can get
backstage to shows and stuff it was
awesome
one time he took me to a pledge of
allegiance tour which was Ramstein
System of a Down corn and Slipknot
actually that's not it was System of a
Down
Rammstein and there's a lot of skinny
white children in that crowd for sure oh
yeah for sure and Slipknot was the main
Act
so we were backstage talking to someone
like you know
lighting guy that Craig knows and uh it
was I mean now as like Years Gone by it
is more like the musicians but it was
always that he's like hey sorry we got
to miss the Encore we have to go say hi
to my friend Tyler who does the fog
machine for whatever yeah you're like
dude what
and he um
so we could [__]
[__] weed dude I've been podcasting
all weekend every podcast has a moment
of me going it's called what the [__]
was I talking about and when we say that
we usually bring up a fan question oh
guys I did it again bring it up so he my
friend Craig backstage goes hey I gotta
go take a piss wait here and kind of
like you know
don't do anything sure
and I'm sitting there and then I just
kind of look over to the right and I see
Waiting by a door is uh Max Weinberg the
drummer for
the E Street Band Bruce Springsteen for
his for always and the drummer for Conan
O'Brien for a bunch of years he was
leader of that band on the show
um and Max weinberg's there with his son
who's I mean a little 12 and he's
dressed in the full Slipknot look at the
dreads and everything coming off it yeah
and I'm just watching this and I'm like
I see Corey Taylor
wow the lead singer he's gone or off off
I didn't know it was I had to find out
it was him yeah I think but he comes out
but he comes out and uh
he goes he goes Max Weinberg it's a
pleasure to meet you and then he sees uh
max weinberg's legs nice to meet you my
uh my son is a humongous like fan of you
guys obviously whenever he's like what's
up little buddy you know he's giving
like a a nice like head rub on the thing
and probably takes a picture I don't
even know all I remember is him just
being like you know acknowledging the
little kid there and I'm like ah what a
neat thing for that kid
um
skip ahead a zillion years I go on tour
with corn and everything
and then maybe like a year or two after
a little more than that maybe like two
years
three years after
they came around to uh on tour with
Slipknot corn so uh I was like oh you
know I asked the drummer I'm like I'll
come see you and hang out so me
and him and my girlfriend are watching
corpsman on first and then he was like
meet me in the sound booth and we'll
watch Slipknot great we're sitting there
watching Slipknot and the drummer from
corn Ray luciegos
um he goes this drummer is like unreal
in this band he goes they gotta keep him
because the other the original drummer
was kicked out of the band Joey jordison
yeah he's dead now but they kicked him
out before but he was out and they were
using like touring drummers and this was
one of the touring drummers but
the corn drummer was like they should
sign him to this band because they're
going to lose him to somebody else if
they don't
and like you know that had no effect on
me and like a concerto didn't weigh on
me I was like crazy you know like that's
not what nice drum drum rumors you know
oh I didn't know we're spilling all the
drummer tea
and then he goes uh and then he just
goes yeah it's actually Max weinberg's
kid shut the [__] and I went yo dude and
I go Weebly and I tell him the whole
story what happened he's like that's
crazy I'm like that's insane that's so
insane it really was so
yeah so many years later
leaving many after that but several
years later I'm at this Chicago Open Air
Festival they gave us backstage passes
but I don't you know you don't want to
be a bothersome thing at all we just
wanted to watch the show so the only
time it made sense to go backstage I was
like I gotta piss let's not wait in line
let's go backstage go to the bathroom I
only see one rock star back there Jay
Weinberg uh Max weinberg's son who's in
Slipknot I'm like this is unreal I gotta
tell them this story
because he knows that moment because I
know since he's posted pictures of that
of that night where he's like isn't it
crazy I met these
so I'm walking over and tell them I get
intercepted he gets intercepted I should
say
buy a couple that starts talking to him
and he's listening to them like very
nicely like kind of hearing their
whatever they're saying and I'm looming
which I hate and I felt it I've I've
seen people have done it to me and I
know I'm doing it where you're just like
yeah he knows I'm waiting to like say so
he feels my girlfriend's going uh she's
like cut it cut it and I go I know I
understand completely how this looks I
go but
this story is too if someone was doing
this to me and when it came up time the
story was like that amazing I'd go you
know if somebody was like dude I sat
behind you for an entire summer and now
I'm seeing you perform it or wherever
you're like I have to tell you this
a couple walks away it's like a weird
amount of time and he starts walking
even though he kind of knew I was
waiting to talk to him so I started
walking next to him I go Jay Weinberg
right and he was like he's like yeah and
I was like nice to meet you I want to
hold you but I have a crazy crazy thing
to my friend Craig I said blah blah blah
where's the thing and you know he goes
uh
I see backstage is Max why oh hey give
me Corey Taylor anyway yeah I'm a
comedian I guess I go on tour the corn
from corn he goes they got to keep this
guy as an amazing it's Max weinberg's
son
and he goes we were walking the entire
time and he just goes
cool man
are you what that's insane and then he
goes and if someone said to me that may
put it in the perspective which maybe
he's right he goes yeah he's like Max
weinberg's son so he's probably not like
he kind of knew he was going to be in a
band that he wanted to be I still think
he should have given it much more than
he gave it but like maybe he's jaded a
little bit or something because I've
always heard he's like a really nice guy
but like he wasn't even a dick he was
just like okay and I'm like no no it's
more than that dude
I happened to be in a hallway watching
Six Degrees of whatever that put me in
that hallway at that moment for no
reason yeah I could have been outside
not seen the whole thing he just goes
wait here while I piss and I see that
whole interaction of the first time you
meet the band when you were a child you
were currently in
yeah I'm gonna start making excuses for
him he deserves that deserve more
a lot a lot more than it could be gave
I'm sorry dude I would have jumped up
like I had to take a piss but I'll be
right back here let's talk hell no I
won't say who but yeah we're gonna take
a picture together or something like
I would have been like I've told that
story on stage I told the story he was
he was like great oh I'm like yo that's
wild nobody else on Earth has ever said
this to you no yeah I have you gotta
respect synchronicity like that yeah you
should that's a really weird thing how
did our pants again also how about right
down the wire of not backstage under any
point that whole day except at the time
we went yeah I gotta go take a piss let
me uh come back today let's go backstage
and take a we'll both go to the bathroom
and then I just he walks off the bus
alone it's just walking I was like Squad
the other couple was definitely probably
they got somebody on the shoulder that
was going like personally goes don't
tell him he's gonna disappoint you when
you tell him
that's a bummer I gotta be honest that's
why I don't uh I mean I haven't made any
like heavy concert effort to meet
Marilyn Manson is because I'm like what
could he do but let me down you know
what I mean the coolest
what if he's the coolest he's like yo
you want to go to the barn go get our
hair done yeah and chest bump you want
to shave our eyebrows off
the first time I heard of Marilyn Manson
I was in third grade remember you used
to make collages here's 18 magazines we
got for free children cut them up and
make a mood board remember that yeah I
remember I made a rocker one and I put
Marilyn Manson when he did the cover and
he had like The Flash rap over his uh
like just over his dick and then he had
like some leather thing why the hell did
they give me that I was in the third
grade right first but it was like a
entertainment or whatever magazine and I
remember everyone went so hard on me for
like six months and just hated me
forever I live in a Mexican ass town
because he was like a devil dude they
just thought that I was that now and I
was like yo did you ever hear his music
he cut his ribs out of his body
it's so great if you read his book like
it's so funny that like he fostered most
of those like room course but he wrote
that book when I believe he was like
much more
coherent no but like understanding of
like what he was
because shock value was different then
because people weren't used to just
everything so when him and Eminem came
out it hit different yeah it hit
different but I mean also just like he
like he would go on like Bill Maher and
shows like that and like
kill it because he would still dress the
part but he was almost telling you he's
like yeah I'm like satire I'm parody and
he's articulous like I'm parodying your
kid he was very articulate and then I
like for some reason why I heard him on
Marilyn on Mark maron's
podcast a while back like Mark's trying
to like you know talk to him he's
interested in him and I feel like
Marilyn Manson was the whole time's like
whatever you know just saying dumb [__]
like he's like I don't know I have to go
home and sacrifice uh a girl I have in a
trunk right now and he's like is that
like a thing do you have like a girl
that's like So Into You she's like into
that stuff he's like or you know I could
stab them with he's just like being a
character and I'm like that sucks man
that sucks I feel like he's become more
of like that guy than like very
articulately like saying like I always
he got me with the Bible thing when they
were like you rip a Bible he goes well
I'm ripping paper he's like you have to
give a [__] by what's on that paper to
make me anything and the only point I'm
making is like if you believe it believe
the words and don't worry if someone's
ripping up p pieces of paper it doesn't
and I was like that's smart like
and again I'm dumb so maybe I'm just
like yo this is gonna be a profit
yeah this guy might be awesome should we
all cut ourselves we're gonna cut your
ribs out oh damn dude going down the
barely Manson Rabbit Hole it does I saw
a video of him yesterday he's just
walking through a rap concert I don't
know if you've seen it you see he's
walking through the crowd of like
a rap show but it's like a festival
where there's a bunch of shows and you
could see he's you know he's with some
chick he's got all Golds yeah he's got
his parted doll hair and it's like a
Lego hair yeah
and then he's got a like a verse like a
all gold Versace outfit on it's like
you're the hardest man to ever live
I hope you're cool in person because
everything about the man is like you're
so dope yeah he's
he's awesome but he's
he's lost it like the thing I just think
the thing is gone you know what I mean
you know the mystique's going because
like again and not that I wish this for
anyone really but I'm like man Marilyn
Manson died like if he was in the 33
club uh yeah bro we're getting to watch
him age he's not doing it I don't know
what the answers
I don't think uh
Tupac was younger he's 25 years old I
thought before 33. no no no no uh Chris
Farley another 27 Club 27 Club 33 is
Chris Farley
there's a bunch of them I know it's
another one Jesus Jesus
um
that's Janice Joplin
Jim Morrison but I was gonna you said
Growing Up In Like A Very Mexican uh
Town Mexican I think goes hard like
metal that's Depeche Mode and they they
love they love the Smiths all the
Mexican girls really they love like sad
[__] with trumpets and some violence and
she think it'd be sad too dude
Hispanic countries are keeping metal
alive and he met when we interview all
the metal guys like they say that like
oh with this big I mean Iron Man Iron
Maiden could [__] sell out like in
Mexico in Mexico like a soccer stadium
oh no for sure I'm just saying like uh
when it comes to
the almost stereotype of what do
Mexicans looks like they listen to these
sad emo [__] but it's sick but if
they're gonna listen to American Rockets
like that all my homies besides my
couple drug dealer friends are all
rocker kids they're literally all
metal kidney my sister she had a liberty
Spike that's why I wanted all the metal
shows because my sister she's a she's a
dick but she's she was cool when we were
kids man and my mom taking a metal show
some [__] yeah I would go to shows I
went to a lot of Tiger Army shows my
first uh Deftones were sick genuinely
still one of my favorite they're great
huh [__] best they never hit a era of
like bad music it's the thing in my face
but it's not that they're all hits I
don't think they've had hits since like
the one late 90s the white pony was that
pony album yeah the album was it was the
song change in the house of flaws thank
you because it was in that uh but you
know what that was that was in the
Queen of the Damned the last thing you
did it was the last thing where she
comes in dancing with that song and that
was like the yeah that's why that song
got very popular
era nipsy hustle John Belushi oh
oh I should have John Belushi because
they almost said like that's what a lot
of people were speculating Chris Farley
was trying to like trying to get the 33.
yeah I don't think so man I know I know
his uh I know his brother very very well
and uh he wasn't trying to die he's just
a drug addict yeah what I say all the
time uh that's why I stopped doing coke
I used to do a lot of coke and I was fat
I'm like I can't do the Chris Farley
route it's like if you're funny
everybody like who you like you have a
little thing going like don't ruin it
I'm 33 years old right now no drugs for
me like I'm trying to keep me off yeah
there's no 34 Club go [__] ham next
year
throw acid in your face no
damn Chris Farley we're just talking
about him recently he got me a picture
for my bathroom it's a
it's Chris Farley down pulled up his
pants in the down by the river skit oh
yeah man just like on the Matt Foley
yeah when he's pulling his pants
um who just got Matt Barnes you know
what you remind me of Chris Farley's
energy he told me that on Monday ago
yeah yeah I can see myself falling down
stoked
go
[__] you Matt Barnes no he was sitting I
went
I appreciate it I feel it's tall no
matter what he can be laying down flat
that feels tall so we took a picture
with him and he sat down while we were
standing no [__] he was still picking
them you're the same way as well
sorry I want to say Alan Iverson for
life and choke them out
Allen Iverson for life
[Music]
he wasn't nice
no no no
not at all what kind of scenario well
actually oh she didn't say he wasn't
like a dick it was just like I was
definitely going to bother him in a
place he didn't want to be bothered and
people jumped in front no it was like a
club that I didn't want to go to I
literally went to it with a guy I know
who works there I was already doing
comedy and they were like you should uh
come to this club and goes whatever it's
called I forget he goes Iverson comes
and hangs out there I was like I do I'd
love to meet him he goes he's the
coolest and I just saw him there and
he's probably the coolest to a bunch of
black people who mostly go to that club
but this fat like I started walking up
and two guys just stood in front of me
and I was like oh I just wanted to like
you know
no say good luck in the playoffs and
then say what a huge fan I mean he was
just kind of like we'll tell him and he
was just like kind of back smoking like
behind them and it's almost like you
hear them doing this to me but whatever
um
so he wasn't a dick he wasn't like a
dick to me he was one of those things
like he didn't want to be bothered like
I was just the idiot that walked up hey
what's up like all day long goes hey
because I'll go to the champ real quick
I always want to say people were
stopping you were always going to go
like you just want to say congrats you
love him you know well there I
understand being like yeah well let him
know totally like I get it now at the
time though in your life sucks yeah I
don't care oh I felt that you've got to
stop and say hi no matter what it is you
I I even if I'm sitting at dinners and
[__] about oh yeah
dude you have to you're you're not wrong
about that I do agree with that you have
to like do what you can like everybody's
experience is like that's the only time
they're ever gonna see the person they
love why never say no to a picture
sometimes like I don't like last week I
was in a club that was small like uh
that's a small their capacity is where
they have a large actually Comedy Room
so the capacity in building isn't much
more than that and then when the other
crowds were coming in before that show
was letting out like it was getting over
like fire code capacity so like they
have to uh like I don't go out after
that show so it's like the people will
move yeah so it's like I get but if I go
out and there's 200 people there to ask
for a picture like I'll just take the
picture and let's again sometimes you
got to be like I can't because I have to
do something but like yeah if you came
to a show I'll sit there and I'm not
like bummed about it either I'm like
yeah they're the only reason that
[__] this works
you can't hate the audience man it's
impossible you have to like
you know I mean respect them at least if
they're not there just none of this
exists exactly exactly if no one's
listening you guys don't get picked up
by this network if no one gives a [__]
exactly dude and I feel like
it's like you with Allen Iverson like
what if you were like I met Allen
Iverson he high-fived the [__] at me we
took a Lethal Weapon picture you would
forever be like yeah I love that but you
still don't know so much but you're like
Sherry he just didn't want to be but you
know you don't ever want to give that
like I I mean at least you know you do
like you're talking to people they're in
the crowd I think with basketball or
Sports it's more like I'm a super
specimen of a human
thank you for buying my jersey yeah yeah
it's different okay
it's like observe me yeah my greatness a
lot of the comedians think like they're
above being in the comments or talking
to the community or really actually
being on level with the fans like I
luckily I would be bad at that and not
out of any kind of like [__] you to the
fans I'm just social media is like I
answer like my messages if I get you
know some of them get dumped and
whatever but like
like I answer my own messages if I can
but like the actual like the posting of
stuff and all that things like I'm
terrible at but the good news is because
I have so much broadcasting I do a week
you know I mean I'm doing
my Series XM shows eight hours a week I
do oh I do four hours I do four hours of
uh Legion of skanks a week and then or
we know three four hours I guess and
then
another podcast that runs an hour that I
do so that's like every Monday through
Wednesday I get all of that in oh damn
yeah oh and then you're on so that's so
that's like and then I'm on the road so
like I'm connected to the fans through
like that they never stop hearing me
tall oh no they would never so it's like
when I you know but I will talk to
everybody after the show and stuff I'll
sit there all day they know what they do
just keep feeding me weed and I'm like
yeah so here's the fourth time I hung
out with Patrice O'Neal
but it never gets exhausting that's so
much broadcasting and then you go right
out Thursday Friday Saturday to a city
and you're back like that's a serious
schedule it's insane
on paper yeah it really is and are you
doing stand-up in New York just on the
regular too no not a ton in the city
anymore because I'm on the road so much
and just like what we like to highlight
is like just how long it takes for
people on their path to really get where
they want to be yeah so like where were
you before when you got picked up on
that corn tour where were you in your
comedy career how far am
um
like 10 years maybe a little over but
right around 10 years I think and then
did it move the needle to the point that
like oh I saw a huge jump in my career
after nope it was more like
like I have a career of like seedlings
it seemed like
and Louis J Gomez from skanks also said
something I always thought was like kind
of
astute the way he said it was like it
sort of works in
10-year phases look at the thing it's
like well there's there's going to be
that group that like just in their 20s
something catches with them and like
they pop and then some people will be
like you know the 30 to 40 is the most
it's at 40. so like that bill Barr
wasn't like known until he was like
close to 40 Louis they always say
careers for sure you know I mean working
always but not like a these are
celebrities now you know and uh at 10
years in I had done a couple I've done
pretty much the things you're supposed
to do having a kid young made the little
things a little different I wasn't like
I had no La Presence at all
I was in New York but I was like so I
was getting in the clubs and stuff there
so I worked locally a ton
and I was able to survive with that and
then David tell took me on the road with
him constantly for years nice which was
awesome when I was a kid it was a show
he had people drink yeah all right I
used to watch that was the best that was
the first tour I did with them was he
was on the Insomniac stand up tour but
like it was named after the show
but um
and I helped all these things happen but
nothing I guess because you're supposed
to go to La and audition for stuff which
also was never my deal like acting I
didn't never over gave a [__] about it
it's such a different thing than stand
up it's weird that there's something I
feel like
broadcasting and stand up has so much
like that's why I love doing both but
acting now nothing like that to me but
um
so I really didn't know what the thing
was going to be I feel like stand up and
then podcasting we started podcasting is
when
things happen and then help that's the
biggest thing is like help from people
man and there's
a bazillion thank yous in my
bibliography from like the first person
put me on stage and was like you did
good man like I'm like I'm proud of you
know I went there and like chickened out
for like four weeks and the fifth time I
tried it and he was like I'm proud I'm
like that meant something
Keith Robinson who took me and Kevin
Hart Out of Philly to like uh New York
basically just kind of show us around
there like it's all and then
kind of in that stagnant phase in my
first 10 years I could do all the stuff
and then it was the second 10 years just
kind of like a little bit of like just
gliding kind of like plateauing
but doing all the stuff still still
working constantly in the clubs doing
my podcast other people's podcast then
we got the radio show
on Sirius and then like weird Schumer
Amy Schumer put me on uh
you know they wrote two or like two
things two or three things for me on her
show to be a part in Louis CK put me on
Louis in three episodes small parts Jim
Jeffries let me open form at Carnegie
Hall because I met him
15 years before that at a festival in
South Africa you know I mean like I said
yeah so all these like uh these just
little pieces you know I mean uh maybe
Kev told a story about me on a podcast
and then it all started kind of and then
the one of the biggest Ari shaffir who
executive produced uh my special that's
coming out
Ari like Comedy Central was kind of like
yeah that guy really nothing really
popped for him so they were kind of out
of the business of me
and then uh Ari fought tooth and nail
for me to be on that storytelling show
and when I did it I did it yeah when I
did it I did well at it in Comedy
Central like really flipped on me they
gave me an hour special and everything
so it's like because of that yeah yeah I
mean Ari is that's like the biggest
factor in Comedy Central specifically
but Ari also got me like my agent that I
still have he still got me so it's like
he's just like that so that's like uh
The Amazing Racist yeah but it is you
just you need people like I feel like
like you need people to like
do all those things like you know to
help you along yeah so like this all
those so what it's about all those
little seeds of things like
I was nice to Amy and then when Amy
Schumer and then she got famous I wasn't
like this [__] like I was kind of over
that phase of like getting jealous and
envious you know I was like oh wow Amy's
big [__] [__] crazy yeah like wow
look at her
because you know it's like when she has
opportunities for me she was like I'd
like you to do this thing I'm like yeah
that's way better than being like I
don't like her because she's making it
of course no we always say a lot of
Judaism it's easy to get there but you
could still get there we're all human
but I mean you have to fight that in
yourself to be like
what's it might I always use is great
some buddies with both and they're both
uh real great guys is uh I remember
being on the road in like a [__] Hotel
good gig but they kind of like [__] me
on the hotel which already felt like
they don't even respect me or whatever
I'm not selling tickets like that and
then something on my phone it was like
Pete Davidson and Michael Che get SNL
and I got so bummed I was like where I
felt the part of it being bummed was I'm
like damn why should I should just be
happy for them I know them they're good
dudes but I'm like [__] man that sucked
and then I kind of sat down and I was
like what I'm all I'm bummed about is
like they're hitting something in their
path I have no interest in being on
Saturday Night Live I mean I've been a
fan of it my whole life so there's
nothing about the show dig on the show
but I'm not a sketch comedy actor it's
not my thing so I'm like why would I get
upset today so then it was more like to
I was able to immediately open myself to
like
I think it's awesome that I can like
text Jay every week and be like Dude
that [__] joke was so hilarious you
know I mean I think that's better than
like having like some weird tension of
course and when you put out that energy
man only good things come back I mean
that's what we preach on the show every
week I remember feeling that like when I
get picked up to headline in like a city
and they like the club makes
the opening comic or something or host
pick you up from the airport or
something like that and it's just like a
50 year old guy who never left town and
I've watched them with me be like
yeah I never heard you before this
weekend but uh I watched some of your
stuff it's like pretty funny it's like
passive aggressive he's not being mean
it would outwardly but he's just going
like
yeah I never heard you before and you're
like well I'm here I'm headlining and
you're hosting the show yeah I'm like
why are you being like I get that
feeling of like why are you being like
kind of like shitty to me like I'm sorry
you didn't make it out of your town to
do your thing it's like a weird so you
gotta fight that though sometimes like I
said it's nature yeah it's human I get
that and that's just because I've said
it before I'm like it's happened to me
where I'm like what am I doing I'm
tripping Fool's gonna crush it I don't
even do that [__] so yeah it's in my
Lane what do I give a [__] and even if
it was it's like damn I better work a
little harder well I had a weird
starting with Kevin Hart though it sets
like an interesting gauge like
someone pointed out to me the other day
which but I've said it before too like
yeah it is it's like a it's a
disheartening thing because like
at my like I'm like in my career I'm
like I think I'm doing all right this is
further probably really that I pictured
ever when I started doing it but I don't
really have a picture I was 19.
uh further along but I mean I am still
and with zero exaggeration
a worth one
500th of Kevin Hart's money do you know
what I mean like and his celebrity for
even that like you know stops traffic if
he walks outside and stuff but I also
got to stand next to him for a couple
times of experiencing that through his
eyes and uh I don't envy that either
honestly if I wanted that I would have
clearly like worked harder to become
like a
like a star in some way but you know in
that regard like a celebrity more than
just like a stand-up comic but like that
is what he wanted to do and like God
bless everybody now just root for Kev
out the ass because I'm like yeah dude I
think my my you know the maybe the most
famous guy in the world used to sleep
over my mom's house once in a while
because we were playing Madden late
pretty [__] wild that's awesome yeah
I'm like I should be happy about this
he's stoked for him yeah not like why
not me he goes because you're not a tiny
black guy that's does what he does like
why we're not going for the same roles
giant white guy can't beat me up for
Soul Plane damn
did you ever see Paper Soldiers one of
his first I was that's when we were
driving back and forth to
um New York from Philly every day so it
was my car generally getting him to
those oh [__] table reads and everything
yeah yeah Patrice from the beginning
yeah
Charlie Murphy's on it it's pretty
pretty ridiculous but the white kid and
their crew yeah Michael when they would
do when they would do table reads before
they had him there because I was just
driving Kev up and I would kind of just
go walk around Rockefeller records oh
[__] meet Damon Dash and stuff I only
got an elevator with Jay-Z once didn't
say a word didn't say a word say a word
but I but Damon Dash was like pretty
cool to talk to at the time he's very
interesting guy and they were the top of
their game at this point and uh yeah I
go to the table reason sometimes I would
read that kids lines for them and I was
almost like like any day now is uh
they're giving the call to make me the
character and I remember the camp was
like we started filming tomorrow I go
did they say that I was that kid that's
been cast for a while now
looking for that character for filming
tomorrow
was that Rapaport
was Michael Rapport in it yeah I think
he was no no no he wasn't the white kid
who that was right before it may have
been in the movie yeah but uh it's like
a younger it was like a younger kid like
uh why I forget I don't think he was a
comic or anything they just got an actor
to do it but he uh
but yeah I remember Paper Soldiers came
out and then uh Soul Plane got leaked
and that was like a big deal like it got
leaked before it was in theaters
so they said black people just boot like
the [__] out of it it was like they made
it a popular cult claim like because
kev's told me before that Soul Plane
actually did do a lot for me even though
the money's [__] because it got leaked
he was like it became such a cult thing
then yeah dude I mean he was like that's
almost it was like worth more than it's
like so plain if it really went into the
theaters would have probably been more
people going like this movie sucks [__]
it's got Hydraulics yeah exactly exactly
are you serious terminal Malcolm X
yo that movie is that movie's the
equivalent to airplane it may have been
it made airplanes are great like almost
a comedy Soul Plane is like was written
by what I would think is a racist it
seems like
it's so
why is it starting off in the black
comedy circuit it is funny how much uh
uh I had to like
I was happy that I didn't like change my
like verbiage you know whatever you know
like the way I talk for to like create a
character I always thought that was like
I always thought that was going like
oh you guys won't understand me unless
I'm like yo yo oh you don't talk like
that I'm like I shouldn't force that of
course but so many white Comics may
start in the black circular go that
route and they'll all say it's always
how they talked but I've always talked
like this
you saw here your son I've been saying
Sons seven years old son that's kind of
real dad called me son
it's not meant to be yeah but like in
comedy I always felt that it would be
like if I change the way I talk because
I think that's what the crowds are
called I'm already pandering in material
yeah that's what it is because I want to
do good but to go up there and be like
oh yo a lot of fun Honey's up in here
like it's I would never is that the way
I talked so I wouldn't do that unless I
was making the joke that if you said
honey yeah it's been a while I heard
that I'm an old man what's up money grip
yo money grip uh
a lot of Spawn Honeys out he remember
flying girls from a Living Color oh that
was hard when I was man honeys
so April 5th
dog belly live from skank Fest uh coming
out on YouTube for free everyone check
it out on your channel Big Jay oakerson
purchase back from the Rev I spent a
gazillion dollars so where's my camera
do it do it's free
but that's it's dog belly April 5th yeah
I'm excited man I'm excited we did it at
our Festival
in Vegas in front of our crowd it's the
jokes that I wanted to do I didn't have
to answer anybody yet
I guess YouTube will take it down if
it's a problem but
I think it's gonna be all right yeah and
are you just if that will go up on
Rumble with the pedal with all the other
crazy fools you're so comfortable in
your act that when you go to film your
special you can go out and just freely
slip in and out of crowd work it seems
like yeah I tried to do that just to
make sure it gets the essence of what I
do because like if I just did a straight
material joke after joke after joke it's
gonna it's not really suggestion because
they we saw a part part of it thank you
very much and I was telling you think
it's like this he's like yeah yeah it
really is shut up
that's really what you're saying a lot
of Commissioners do a Verbatim almost
like a musician going out doing their
album but it's like you don't see that a
lot people with the skill to like no
yeah I don't want to do it because it
would be so boring for me that's what I
said that it becomes work
that's not why I got this to work but
the reality is there's so much work
around this to travel the thing it's
like it's crazy the schedule you have to
keep and all the stuff we're doing but
at the end of the day
that's why I said the work is like all
that travel is when you land and go to a
hotel and blah blah blah and unpack and
all this [__] you don't feel like doing
this was ultimately culminating in me
sitting on a stool and being like what's
your problem jerk off
but in the end banging this [__] it's
done everything yeah it's right that's
what I'm saying so it's a it's a
the complaint is never about like you
know I said it is like hard work to say
it's not hard work I've almost gone
easier on myself because I always be
like I've done like manual labor jobs
before you know I mean like wheelbarrow
and concrete
so you're like this is the thing and
they go no but still like you know you
have to be places and do something and
keep your mind sharp yeah that's what I
was going to say you know say a bunch of
you know keep topics fresh and new and
it's like so you're working and I'm like
now I know but it's just like
I've you know I've taught a roof with
someone before and I'm like that but the
beauty of what I get to do with
especially broadcasting not even so much
the stand up
and that's what fuels my audience for my
stand-up is that I'm now entertaining A
guy who's tarring a roof who gets to
laugh while he's just getting through
his [__] day of his [__] job that pays
good you know like that do you remember
that oh yeah for sure and Howard Stern
Howard Stern always kind of said that
thing he's like I'm here to entertain
you through shitty stuff
so yeah that's the point of the show
yeah so work everybody watch your show
Legion Escape so when do you anywhere
you get podcasts that comes out every
Monday and Friday Monday uh yeah on uh
anywhere you get podcasts
uh we go live Mondays at
8pm whatever on time eight something
eight weeks yeah we're live I'm sorry we
go live on our website uh gasdigital.com
gasdigital.com yes indeed nice man and
your dog Billy drops April 5th on what's
your uh YouTube just picture yeah I'm
spelled out yep not comedy anymore nope
all right you got it and you got
helicopter dates coming up you guys yeah
I'm all overcomedy.com for all my dates
man I'm I'm all over the place big
jcomedy.com you you have a lot some I
see some of those dates you're doing
multiple shows in a day oh yeah yeah
yeah no well the weekends always is that
like I go to Spokane
Friday and I had to do two that night to
the next night but they're comedy club
stuff it's like the theater's a little
different if you're doing two theater
shows that's like a lot
that'll happen too I hope at some point
but the comedy clubs that's always kind
of the schedule
he knows he's from that that game same
thing if I did my like front to back
same thing each time that's why I would
just go nuts with that person I'm like a
traveling play it's like each thing's
got its own weird situation going on see
that's what I was thinking like this is
not scripted yeah it's like almost
freestyle like yo you didn't plan that
I'm wearing a purple shirt today you had
no idea that's a completely different
that's a completely different thing yeah
damn upset you're the Jay-Z a comedy
that's where we're getting out of here
oh thank you
freestyling I know I appreciate you man
thank you man no we gotta wrap up but
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having me man it's just big Jay
oakerson on all Social Security yeah all
right across Twitter Instagram we
appreciate it we've had a bunch of
legendary Comics we're glad to have you
on
thank you appreciate you guys from Marty
and I from Big Jay oakerson have a dope
ass day that second joint
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show telehoney